hamon
[Musique]
c'était fini
départ est confirmé je te souhaite que
mon client n'a qu'un concept mais
possède un bar du centre et notre
mission pour toi un voyage doit partir
en safari
à 12h37 watts au crime elle c'est son
job elle avait pas qui est un grand mois
olivia dallas
le sens de l'art osé tant qu'homme je
suis quand même
vous avez des bouffées de la testeuse
parce que je voudrais qu'on arrête tout
de suite je regrette madame tu veux la
paix cette manne 1 et qui va lui dire
que s'il touchent à mon mec de lui
défonce la tête vous êtes mariés depuis
longtemps d1 s'est passé tellement vite
que j'ai l'impression qu'on vienne se
regrouper mais bon ça suffit la monsieur
nelson je vous présente clémence bonjour
la dass et johnny nous ta femme
[Musique]
moi qui envoyer à notre adresse et sa
femme qui peut devenir ça m a dit je
cherche votre mari vous l'avez vu non
incapable de faire confiance aux cuves
ans
t'as pas y avoir deux femmes et ces
femmes six mois non ici sa femme c'est
moi
[Musique]